>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Nanette Gibbs: Good morning
and welcome to the second
of the eight lectures
in our series this year.
I am Nanette Gibbs from
the Library of Science,
Technology and Business Division.
Today we'll hear about
NASA's mission to send groups
of astronauts, engineers, and
scientists to live and work
in Aquarius, an undersea research
station off the coast of Key Largo.
Crew members encounter
conditions and challenges similar
to what they might experience on
asteroids or a moon or on Mars.
They are able to simulate living
on a spacecraft and contest
and develop tools and techniques
for future space missions.
Doctor Young, who is a research
scientist and planetary geologist,
is a graduate of McLean
High School and earned a BS
in Environmental Geosciences
from Notre Dame and an MS and PhD
in geological sciences from
Arizona State University.
She spoke here last
October on developing tools
and training astronauts for
planetary surface exploration.
Please help me welcome Kelsey
Young back to the library.
[ Applause ]
>> Kelsey Young: Okay hi
everyone, thanks Nanette and thanks
to the library for having
me back a second time.
So I'm going to be
talking about NEEMO today,
which is NASA's underwater
analog project.
But first, I was going
to introduce myself,
but Nanette pretty
much covered that.
So I am a field geologist and I
do field geology here on Earth
to prepare for when human beings
go back beyond low Earth orbit.
So I spend a lot of time out in
analog environments, I just got back
about thirty-six hours
ago from California
where I was doing fieldwork
with this instrument here.
So we're testing instruments
and operational concepts
for human beings when they
go and conduct science
on other planetary surfaces.
So I'll talk to you a little bit
about solar system exploration
and the role that the NEEMO project
in particular will play in it.
So here's our solar system.
Human beings have never ventured
beyond our planet and its moon,
but we have sent orbiters, rovers,
and landers out to the far
reaches of the solar system.
Most recently the new horizons
mission went out even past the end
of our solar system and just
last week Cassini actually went
through Saturn's rings.
So there's a lot going on in solar
system exploration, but what I want
to focus on today is human
exploration in particular.
So we've only ever sent human
beings beyond our planet
on six different missions
from 1969 to 1972.
Twelve people walked on the surface
of the moon, collecting samples,
deploying surface science
experiments,
and on the later three missions,
actually using the lunar
roving vehicle pictured here
to travel even farther away
from where they landed.
The scientific experiments they
were doing were pretty basic,
they were using basic tools like
rakes, shovels, scoops, to collect
and store samples for
return to Earth
and those samples are
still being studied today
at the Johnson Space Center.
And then they also
deployed science experiments
like basic seismic packages to
look at the seismic structure
of the upper lunar crust.
And the lunar roving vehicle
was used to transport all
of these samples and experiments
as well as store samples
to bring back to the Lander.
To do this, to practice
for what they were going
to be doing during Apollo,
the twelve Apollo astronauts
who actually ended up walking
on the moon spent a great deal
of time learning geology
and field testing technology
that they were going
to use on Apollo.
Geologists like to say that the
Apollo astronauts essentially had
earned the equivalent of a
Master's degree in geology
by the time they flew to the moon.
So they really knew what they were
doing, they were highly trained
by a group of skilled field
geologists, and so they learned
about geology and analog
sites here on Earth,
and then they also field tested
the technology that they were going
to use once they got to
the surface of the moon.
So this is the Apollo 17 crew
actually using the cameras
and technology that they'd
eventually used during Apollo 17,
as well as doing things
like testing the suits
and the lunar roving vehicle
in relevant environments
to the landing site that they
were going to be visiting.
So this idea of field testing
technology in preparation
for exploration has
been around a long time
and it was incredibly successful
in the Apollo generation.
In fact, the Apollo astronauts
who received the most training
toward the later Apollo missions
were actually incredibly
successful in collecting samples
that are a really robust part of
the Lunar Science Community today.
Today we continue that
tradition of testing technologies
and operational procedures
in relevant environments.
Here are just some of the
environments that we're working
on today, we have aquatic,
terrestrial,
and laboratory environments.
For aquatic, I'll talk to you today
a lot about the NEEMO experiment,
but we also have the
Neutral Buoyancy Lab
at the Johnson Space Center
where there's full-size mockups
of the International Space
Station for the astronauts
to actually practice
EVAs or spacewalks on.
ESA, the European Space Agency
also has their own neutral
buoyancy facility.
Terrestrially, we do a lot.
Here is another analog project
similar to NEEMO called Desert Rats
where rovers actually drive around
in analog environments to prepare
for when we're back on
either the Moon or Mars.
We actually train astronauts
in relevant field areas,
just like we did in Apollo.
So we take out all the astronauts
today into places like New Mexico
and Arizona to train them for
what they're going to be viewing
from orbit and what they're
hopefully going to be seeing
when they go past low Earth orbit.
And we also go to extreme
environments from Antarctica
up to the Arctic to test
procedures and learn about processes
that shape other planetary surfaces.
In the laboratory we have things
like the ARGOS environment,
the Active Response
Gravity Offload System,
which actually simulates
what it's like to work
in lower gravity than here on Earth.
We use virtual reality
and hybrid reality
to actually immerse
ourselves in environments
like we see on other planets.
So we can actually put ourselves
on Mars and offload our gravity
to experience what it
would be like on Mars,
to simulate what astronauts
are really going
to be feeling once they get there.
And then we have the
International Space Station.
So human beings are living every day
up in space, a couple hundred miles
above our heads, and that's a really
robust laboratory to learn what it's
like to work in microgravity.
So we're learning about the health
effects of long-term spaceflight,
which is going to be really
important on the journey to Mars.
And the ISS is the most robust
laboratory environment we have
to really prepare for
long-term spaceflight.
But what we really want to spend a
lot of time doing and what I'm going
to be talking about for the rest
of today are conducting highly
integrated operational tests.
So what I mean by that
is, operational tests sort
of combine science operations and
equipment or technology together
in a mission-like environment to
really simulate what it's going
to be like to be on
the Moon or Mars.
So the types of things
that we're evaluating
in these operational tests
include concept of operations.
So what is it actually going to look
like when human beings are
operating on the surface.
During Apollo, we had two
human beings operating together
at one time.
For three of the six missions
they had the lunar roving vehicle.
When we go back beyond Earth, things
are not going to look the same.
Technology has come a long way,
operational concepts have come a
long way, and we need to practice
to understand what these operational
concepts are going to look
like when we hopefully
head back to the moon.
We also want to test
relevant hardware and tools
for both pioneering and science
tasks, and what I mean by that is,
you know, I'm a geologist,
I'm looking forward
to when astronauts bring back
samples from other planets,
so that's sort of a
science task similar
to what the Apollo guys were doing.
So they were actually
picking up rocks based
on their geology training
and returning them to Earth.
We're also going to have
pioneering tasks, so what I mean
by that is basically if we
have long-term spaceflight
and human beings are living on
another planetary surface for longer
than the couple days they
were there on Apollo,
they'll have pioneering tasks to get
ready for that long-term habitation.
So they'll set up habitats, they'll
set up communication structures,
they'll deploy sort of
weather monitoring stations
on the surface of Mars.
So we need to simulate what those
pioneering tasks look like now
because we've never done that
on another planetary surface.
So we need to test the
relevant hardware and technology
that they're going to be
using when they're doing that.
And we also want to look
at the tools and techniques
that enable the communication
between Earth,
which will have a mission control
center, MCC, and a science team just
like they had on Apollo,
and the crew.
And something I'm going to
talk a lot about today is sort
of the difference between
IV and EV crew.
So EVA is an Extra
Vehicular Activity, spacewalk,
it's what the Apollo astronauts
did when they spent, you know,
eight hours at a time
roving over the surface.
We're hoping we'll get, you
know, more than two crew members
to another surface in the future,
and if that's the case we'll
likely have an IV crew member
or an intra-vehicular
activity crew member,
who's sitting inside a habitat
and helping to get eyes on an EVA
and sort of quarterback the EVA.
So I'll talk about that later
in the context of NEEMO.
But we want to sort of stress these
tools and techniques that are going
to enable this communication between
Earth and the supporting teams
and the crew who are
actually doing the science.
And we want to do this over an
appropriate communication delay.
So Mars is far enough away that when
you send up communication to Mars,
it's going to take a long
time for it to get there,
it doesn't get there right away.
So actually a communication loop
between if I am sitting here
on Earth sending a communication to
somebody on Mars, it's going to take
as much as thirty minutes
to get there and back.
So if you say, oh wow, I see this
amazing rock in your video screen,
you know, that was
fifteen minutes ago, right,
so you need to understand how to
flux the scientific operations
over this long communication delay.
And what we want to do is do
that using a flexible execution
methodology, and what we mean
by that, and I'll talk about
that a lot in this talk,
is basically you go in
with a traverse plan.
The Apollo astronauts had their
eight hours pretty much scripted
and they knew exactly where
they were going to go,
when they were going to go there.
What we want to do is give
astronauts the technology
and the training to be able
to actually flexibly
execute those traverses.
So if they're driving down the
dotted line on their traverse map
but they see something to the left
off the traverse map we want them
to be able to be empowered
to go and investigate it.
The extreme example we use is if
an astronaut is on Mars and they're
on this traverse path and
they see a dinosaur bone off
to the left that's not
on the traverse path,
we want them to turn left
and pick up the bone, right?
So that's sort of flexible
execution.
So we call it flexicuting [phonetic]
a traverse plan, so I'll talk a lot
about that today with NEEMO.
So basically all of this together,
we want to combine science,
operations, and technology in
a mission-like environment.
So to do this, we go
out on the field,
we go out on relevant
analog environments.
So these analog missions allow for
really early end-to-end testing
of operational concepts
and hardware.
So these are just a couple examples
of the analog missions NASA's run,
here's NEEMO which
I'll talk a lot about.
Here are those desert rats
missions where we simulated being
on the surface of the Moon.
And the types of things we're doing
are we're evaluating objectives
that map to specific
knowledge or technology gap.
So we're not ready go to Mars, NASA
is not ready to send humans to Mars.
We have knowledge and technology
gaps before we can get there.
Analog missions are
hoping to close some
of these knowledge
and technology gaps.
We want to put the crew in
a flight-like environment,
and also the ground team in
a flight-like environment.
So it's not just the crew that's
going to be involved in exploration,
it's all of us here on Earth and
we need to be trained for that.
These types of operational
tests, they drive out results
that aren't found when you're just
testing one tool or one technique
at a time, you need
to really put this
in a robust stressing
environment that's going
to stress the entire system and
stress the participants involved.
And this has benefits right now on
ISS, I'll talk to you about this
but last year we were
deploying experiments on ISS
that a couple months later, or
excuse me, deploying experiments
on NEEMO that a couple months
later were deployed on ISS.
So the types of testing we're doing
in these analog missions have,
you know, current relevance
to ISS as well
as to NASA's future
exploration goals.
So bit of an [inaudible], but
this is just to show you the types
of things that we're
doing to prepare for,
for hopefully sending humans to
Mars and the types of experience
that teams working
here on Earth have.
So Apollo is a big part of
our experience, you know,
we learned a lot from
the Apollo missions.
There are still people that
I work with today that were
around in the Apollo age, but that's
not going to continue forever,
these people are retiring.
So we need to learn all we can now
from the people who really did this,
the only time we've ever sent
human beings to another surface.
We have Mars robotic missions.
So we have two functioning rovers
on the surface of Mars right now,
they're obviously not human
beings but they require constant,
constant supervision and sending
up new traverse plans every day.
There are Mars rover
planners working every day
to develop the new ops plans for the
two rovers that are up there now,
and that's under this
communication delay.
So right now we're
learning how to do science
under a communication delay and
it's incredibly valuable experience.
We have NEEMO which I'll
talk about that's been run
since the early 2000s, we have the
desert rats rover missions which,
similar to NEEMO but above water.
We have a number of
science field campaigns
and other relevant environments that
are considerably smaller in scale
than NEEMO, I just got back from
one of them a couple days ago.
So all of these things together
are really, we're hoping,
going to together prepare us
for hopefully putting boots
on the ground on Mars.
But NEEMO, the rest of
the day I'm going to talk
about the NEEMO Analog
Project in particular.
NEEMO stands for the NASA Extreme
Environment Mission Operations test,
it's been run in the Aquarius
habitat since the early 2000s.
And it's run through the
Aquarius Reef Base Facility,
that's run by Florida
International University.
So I'll talk to you a little bit
about the Aquarius Reef Base
Facility and then sort of jump
in to the recent NEEMO missions and
sort of what we're learning today
and what we'll deploy in NEEMO
22 in a couple of months.
So this is the shore facility
that we use for the NEEMO tests.
It's located in Islamorada,
Florida in the Florida Keys,
so sort of all the operation
centers are in this building.
There's a watch desk which I'll
show you a picture of in a second
where whenever a crew is in
saturation in the habitat,
there's somebody sitting at the
watch desk twenty-four seven
to monitor the health of the
habitat and the health of the crew.
There's a mission control center
where the NASA team sets up to sort
of pretend like we're in the
mission control center in Houston,
and there's a number of dive
lockers for the support staff
that support the crew in saturation.
So here's sort of a map
of the Florida Keys,
like I said the mission
control center in the building
on the previous slide is run by FIU,
Florida international University,
and it's about an hour
and a half south of Miami.
Here's the watch desk, that's
again manned twenty-four seven
and it's situated right here on one
of these canals, the ARB facility.
If you just go six
miles offshore you get
to the Aquarius habitat
which is pictured here.
So this is sort of a model
of Aquarius Reef Base itself.
The bottom of the habitat sits
at sixty-two feet of water
but the bottom of the
habitable volume, which is here,
sits at a little shallower
at fifty feet.
So this is the, these are the
dimensions of the habitable volume,
nine feet in diameter and
forty-three feet long.
And here's sort of a
sketch of the volume
that the crew spends
all of their time in.
So they basically come in through
the wet porch, they just swim down
and up into the habitat, and this
is sort of the size of the space
that they're living in,
sort of like a big RV.
So they have sort of areas
to do science experiments,
they have a dining room
table to eat dinner at,
and then they have bunks back
here, as well as several viewports
where they can actually look
outside at what's around them,
including one at the
back right by their beds.
So here's a view from the bunk
room looking sort of down,
looking from the bunks
down this way.
So here's the outside of the
hab, and this is the viewport
that they can see from their beds
and here are the bunks themselves,
there are six bunks,
three on each side.
And here are just some
pictures to give you an idea
of what it looks like
inside Aquarius.
We've got, sort of, it's a very
small working space and they can,
you know, sort of eat and do
science on either side of it.
This is the wet porch that
they can swim up and in,
and in general it's
a lot like, you know,
living on the International Space
Station, it's a cramped environment,
you're in there with a lot of
people, so hopefully you get along
with the other five
people in the habitat.
Here are the onshore
facilities that we have,
that the ARB, the ARB facility has.
There's a fleet of boats to take
divers to and from the dive site,
there's the NASA office and
the mission control center
like I mentioned, Internet,
conference meeting area, labs,
you know, computers, a
workshop area in case, you know,
they actually need to machine
anything, dive lockers, a rest area,
and they actually have a hyperbaric
chamber and safety equipment in case
of an incident or accident
happening during a mission,
which has never happened,
not to worry.
And there's also a life-support
buoy out at the site itself.
So Aquarius sits underwater
underneath the life-support buoy,
it's got generators,
compressors, communications
to bring back the comps
from the crew directly
to the facility onshore, and again
it sits directly above the habitat,
and here's a human
up here for scale.
So Aquarius sits in
the Carpenter Basin,
so Aquarius is actually
labeled AQ right here,
that's where the habitat is, and
this is just to give you an idea
of the scale of the sort
of the exploration area
of the crew during a mission.
These are all sort of landmarks
that the team has worked
out over a number of years,
some of these are sampling sites
from previous NEEMO missions
which I'll talk about.
This data or this map is
overlain on bathymetry data,
so you can actually see the
sort of dimensions of the bottom
of the sea floor here, you can
see sort of lots of striations
in the floor and that's actually,
you know, coral features that are
on the bottom of the sea floor
which is actually what the
astronauts are exploring
when they're out on simulated EVA.
So all of this together
really enables NASA to operate
in a high fidelity environment.
So we can test operational
concepts and procedures
in a space-like environment,
we can play with usability
and design trade-offs.
So it enables us to
be in an environment
where we can really test different
types of technology year after year
after year and experiment with
the trade-offs that are involved
with one technology over another.
It enables us to build up a
workforce that's knowledgeable
and experienced in this type of
exploration, which is really,
really important as we, you know,
hopefully build past the Earth.
It builds these workforce
knowledge gaps, like I said earlier,
on how to execute really
complex operational procedures.
It has early and relevant
and operator input.
So the astronauts are the
ones that are going to be
out on these other
planets doing exploration,
and it enables these people, these
astronauts to get in this habitat
and get their hands on
developing technology.
So it gets them experience,
but it also enables them
to give us experience.
So if there's a technology that
they really just don't like
or don't think is going to work in
spaceflight, this is a way for us
to work that out early
rather than when, you know,
we're on our way to Mars.
And lastly, and I think it's really
important, it's a proven PAO tool,
a public outreach tool, for
keeping the public inspired
and engaged in space exploration.
We may not have humans beyond
Earth and ISS right now,
but we are working toward,
you know, sending humans,
putting boots on the ground on
Mars and it's really important
that the public be
engaged in that effort.
So diving into NEEMO 21,
diving puns [laughter].
So NEEMO 21 was this
past year in 2016,
the mission was actually sixteen
days long, living and working
in the Aquarius Reef Base Facility.
We had completed a variety of
objectives which I'll talk to you
in the next slide, we had
an international crew,
which actually a part of the
crew rotated out mid-mission.
So here are the crew here, we had
Americans, one from South Africa,
one from Germany, and
one from Ireland.
So we had an engineering week
where we actually tested a lot
of the technology that we are going
to be using during the missions,
that was well in advance of
the mission to sort of iterate
on any design requirements
that needed to be changed.
We had a crew training week
at the Johnson Space Center
where all the crew members
flew to Houston and enabled all
of the mission operators
to train them on the types
of technology they
were going to be using.
We had a test readiness review
which is actually where we sit
with the safety officers
at the Johnson Space Center
to make sure everyone's comfortable
with putting these test
subjects in this environment.
We had a training week actually
down in Florida just the week
before the mission to, you know,
get hands-on training
and teach the divers,
teach the crew members how
to do saturation diving.
And then we had the mission
which was sixteen days long.
So I want to talk to you about
the science and operations
and technology advancements
from the mission.
Do not worry about
reading this slide,
this is just to show
all the partners
that we had for the mission.
So a really unique and exciting
thing about NEEMO is that, you know,
it's run by NASA at NASA, but we
have a lot of external partners
that enables a big part of
the community to get involved,
and that's contributed a lot
to the success of this program.
So this is just a graphic
to show you all the partners
that we had involved
in this mission,
and I'll talk about the
contributions from several of them
over the course of this talk.
Suffice it to say we had a
lot of NASA centers involved,
we had PIs from different
research institutions involved,
we had several academic
institutions,
private research institutions,
we had the military involved,
and we had a number of
different contributors
from industry across the country.
So our science objectives,
I'll give a high-level overview
and then I'll dive into a
little bit of detail there.
One of our objectives was
nursery construction and science,
and I'll talk about that
in the next couple slides.
But we partnered with the
Coral Restoration Foundation,
which is a nonprofit based in
the Keys, it's actually working
on exploring why corals
are dying off.
You might've heard in the news,
there are corals all over the world,
including the Great Barrier
Reef, that are really struggling.
So the Coral Restoration
Foundation is trying
to understand why this is happening
and perhaps more importantly figure
out how to repopulate
some of these reefs.
So NEEMO has a big
part in that research
and I'll talk about that in a bit.
We have follow-up science,
and that's because, you know,
NASA has been working in this
area for a number of years,
specifically in NEEMO
20 was the first year
that we had really
integrated science objectives,
coral science objectives,
with the NEEMO program.
So the crew in NEEMO 20 back in
2015 collected a bunch of samples,
and we went back in NEEMO 21
to investigate how those
sites have changed over time.
We also had new exploration, so this
is sort of an exploration zone map
of the Carpenter Basin
around Aquarius.
We had five exploration zones
that the crew could go in
and those are sort of just, those
exploration zones were defined
so that, you know, both the ground
control team and the crew could sort
of reference something on
a map and have something
to track back to for
mission planning.
So now through from NEEMO
20 to NEEMO 21 last year
through NEEMO 22 this year,
we have really authentic robust
coral science that's fully
integrated into NEEMO
EVA operations,
so that's really exciting,
it's something, you know,
the NEEMO team is really proud of.
And we're doing this under, you
know, a lot of hours of EVA.
So we had over 60 hours of
science-based EVA last year
and we were able to get a lot of
really exciting coral science done.
So here's the Coral
Restoration Foundation, again,
they're a nonprofit organization
and they're dedicated to creating
and maintaining these
offshore nurseries
for threatened coral species.
So they want to build these coral
nurseries and restoration techniques
and understand what the best
way is to restore these reefs
and empower others and train others
to do the same thing
around the world.
So here are some of the types of
nurseries that CRF is working with
and they're spread over a
number of different locations,
and I'll talk to you specifically
about the nursery work that's
going on in the NEEMO area.
So for NEEMO we work
extensively with CRF,
CRF is able to prepare the
astronauts, process the corals,
train the astronauts, and
train the ground control team
to support the mission.
So the corals are actually
put on these little sort
of like credit card or playing
card size little pieces of plastic
and they're sort of cultivated
in the CRF facility in the Keys.
This is actually Ken Nedimyer who
runs CRF and he's a big partner
of NEEMO and we've really
enjoyed working with CRF.
And so here they are
sort of training the crew
in the onshore facility on how
to actually physically
construct the trees
because in NEEMO 21 the crew
actually took these cards
that the coral scientists
prepared and mounted them
on the coral trees
themselves underwater
where they've been
since last August.
So once the sort of
cards were constructed
and the crew was trained, we
had to physically transport them
to the site, so took them out
on a boat and put them here
in these sort of milk crates here.
And the crew actually took them
to the two sites designated
in the Carpenter Basin and deployed
five of these trees at each site,
and each tree has 100
coral cards on it.
So we really do have
a lot of coral colony
or coral species growing underwater
now and they've been under there
for almost a year, so this year
we're going to be able to go back
and see how they're doing.
So these are just some
of the process
of the crew last year actually
setting up the nurseries.
And one of the cool fun facts
from last year that we actually
on purpose did not tell the crew
until the day of this relevant EVA,
but they built the deepest coral
nursery in the world last year,
so that's really exciting.
And they're comparing the, the coral
scientists are comparing the shallow
nurseries and the deep nurseries to
compare which species grow the best
at which depths and in
which water conditions.
So then we actually wanted to
conduct science and operations
on the nurseries, so here's Ken and
our science team mission control,
this is the science team here
in our little trailer outside
in the parking lot of
the onshore facility.
And so they're actually, they
mounted all the coral cards
and then took pictures of all of
them so the coral scientists back
in the trailer could evaluate
which corals even survived the trip
because corals are fragile that's,
you know, one of the reasons we're
in this situation and we wanted
to make sure that that journey
out to Aquarius and
underwater, they made it through.
So that a year from now, we'll
know that any of the corals
who died off actually occurred in
the year since they were planted,
not the initial effort of
getting them out there.
So for marine exploration
science, we've partnered
with the Images Lab at FIU.
So it's the Integrative Marine
Genomics and Symbiosis Lab at FIU,
just a really robust
coral science facility.
And they have a lot of science
objectives, we've partnered
with them since NEEMO 20, and
they're doing real science
on these coral colonies
with the samples
that the NEEMO crews are collecting.
So in NEEMO 20 they were sampling
the Siderastrea type of coral,
I've learned a lot about coral
in the last couple years.
And then in NEEMO 21 they were
looking at the Agaricia species
and the Orbicella species
as well as, again,
actually doing some science on
the coral colonies themselves.
So they wanted to genetically
characterize the types of corals
from the depths that they're,
that they're collected from.
They want time and
depth constraints.
So precisely when they
were collected
and from what depth
is really important
when you're thinking
about coral science.
So we have to train the
crew to really pay attention
to their depth gauges
and making sure
that the corals they're
collecting are
at relevant depths
for the science team.
And we want to provide
a natural baseline
for those coral restoration efforts.
So they're exploring the
local corals to figure
out how they might relate to the
corals that are on the nurseries.
And so this ultimately,
they want to influence
and inform the coral
restoration efforts as well
as understanding this, you know,
really this reef environment
that's really in flux.
So that's sort of the
science we're doing,
but moving on to the science
operation, so what it's actually
like to conduct science in
this relevant environment.
Again, I'll go into a couple,
into detail about some of these,
but we looked at integrated
EVA science operations.
So what the communication
structure between a crew on EVA,
their supporting crew member
who's sitting inside the habitat,
the mission control center, and
the science team back on Earth.
So that's, you know, four
variables who, you know,
all want to get their
opinions heard.
So flexing this communication
structure became, you know,
really important to test
and last year, in NEEMO 21,
we did this under a fifteen minute
one way communication delay.
So again if I'm sitting
in the science trailer
and I send a communication
to the crew,
it gets there fifteen
minutes later, they read it,
they have to send a response
and fifteen minutes later
I see their response.
So we're flexing this
communication structure
under this high communication
latency.
So then we had navigation map
and traverse planning
science operations objectives
that we were testing.
We used different navigation
technologies as well
as crew training and sort of IT
assets to have actually on EVA,
I'll talk about that in a bit.
Just to briefly mention, we had an
optical communications experiment
deployed by a student group from
Embry-Riddle Aeronautical University
with us last year, and we had a
remotely operated vehicle, an ROV,
from the Naval postgraduate school
that was also tested last year.
But to dive into this sort
of communication structure
a little bit more,
this is sort of just an
image to show, you know,
here's us in the science
trailer last year
who were actually communicating
directly with the intra-vehicular,
the IV crew member here which
I'll talk about in a bit,
who then could communicate
with the EV crew member.
And things to think
about is that, you know,
there's a communication delay
between science team and IV,
but there's no communication delay
between the habitat and the people
who are boots on the ground.
So experimenting with this
communication delay where it occurs
and where it matters
became really important
in developing the technology
to support that delay,
to support communication
over the delay,
is something that's iteratively
tested from year to year with NEEMO.
So our objectives with looking
at this integrated science operation
structure last year were just
to figure out how this works,
operate it under a
communication delay,
and there are definitely kinks but
those kinks are results, right?
So we want to determine
what functions
and capabilities are needed by every
part of that communications loop
to enable them to do their job.
For example, this IV person,
one of the things we found
was they are very busy,
they are extremely busy,
they have mission control
and science team saying, ooh go
collect that coral, that was great,
and mission control
saying, okay EVA,
one hour left, you've
got to hurry up.
And then you have the EV crew
streaming back all this data to them
that they're trying to
keep control of and manage.
So giving them the technology
that they need to manage all
of those different variables is one
of the main takeaways from NEEMO.
And then one of the other things
that I mentioned earlier is this
flexicution [phonetics] idea.
Flexicution [phonetics], it
sounds sort of straight forward,
flexible execution, not something
that NASA's really done before.
We operate under scripted timelines.
And being able to go to
NASA and say, you know,
scientists really need astronauts
to be able to be flexible,
is like this whole new language,
but it's a language we're starting
to learn and we're
starting to understand.
So this is, you know, something
I spend a lot of my time thinking
about and I think it's
not straight forward
but it's definitely a big hurdle,
but it's an exciting one I think.
So the takeaways from this
sort of study last year was
that we successfully exercised these
full comm loops with passing a bunch
of data back and forth,
communications from the crew
to the science team and
back to the EV via the IV,
we sort of stressed this whole
loop over the sixteen-day mission
and really felt like we
had a number of situations
that presented themselves where we
got to stress that system and put it
under pressure a little bit, which
is important in tests like this.
And so we also observed
the criticality
of these flexicution
[phonetics] flight rules.
So being able to be flexible is
important and training a crew
so that they feel confident
enough in a science
to be flexible is important and it's
something we did last year in NEEMO,
but we also want to have flight
rules, right, like unbreakable rules
that no matter what, no matter if
there's a dinosaur bone over there,
there are rules that
you cannot break, right?
So developing those flight rules is
really important and it's something
that we'll certainly have, you know,
nailed down when we send
human beings beyond Earth.
So another objective we had
was, again, assessing the tools
and technology needs, and this
includes both hardware and software,
so the tools that the
astronaut are actually holding,
what that hardware looks like,
as well as what's displayed
on screens and things like that.
So we're assessing the tools needs
for both short distance navigation
from site to site to site to
support this type of geology
or in this case coral science.
So the takeaways are that the crew
successfully used digital maps,
digital traverse plans,
and an active system
to locate pertinent sampling zones.
So they had this this navigation
equipment they were using
and they also had basically an
underwater iPad that they were able
to actually view traverse plans
with and sampling procedures with.
So here's a traverse for
one of the days last year
that they're actually able
to navigate with underwater.
So they were actually able
to successfully do that,
but one of the key lessons learned
for us on the shore side of things,
the science team side of
things, is under this sort
of time latent planning cycle, so
with a high communications delays,
we need to make sure that we update
the plan, we keep them apprised
as our plans evolve from one day
to the next in a timely manner
so that they can sit down
before they go EVA and say,
okay here's the plan, we know
this plan is not going to change.
Here's the flight rules,
here's the traverse plan,
if we see this we deviate
from the traverse plan,
but only if it's within
the [inaudible].
They have to have that information
with enough time to feel confident
that the crew can really effectively
and efficiently operate the plan.
So technology too, sort of similar
to the last slide I just talked
about but, what we're looking
at is digital cue cards.
So here's that underwater
iPad we are testing
and they were actually able
to pull up all sorts of things
on these underwater iPads and
I'll about that in a second.
The IV support system, like I
mentioned, it was really important
to give the IV person the assets
they needed to be successful
in a really busy position.
We also had science sampling
tools and a geology sampling kit
that the EVA tools group at the
Johnson Space Center is developing.
So they tested that extensively
and NEEMO as well last year.
So here's sort of the digital
cue card, they had mission maps,
they had the images
and traverse plans,
they had the Marine science
procedures as well as sort
of a guide to help them identify
coral, they had procedures for how
to build the coral nurseries, they
had procedures for how to operate
that sampling kit I just mentioned,
procedures for optical comm,
a list of equipment and how to
use it, and then a number of sort
of operationally minded things to
enable them to flip back and forth
between all of those assets.
So they had procedures
that they could pull up,
this is the geoscience sampling
procedure that with one click
of a button they can get
there on the underwater iPad.
And so that enables
them to really pull
up what they need at
a drop of a hat.
It also implies that they're highly
trained in how to use the iPad
which is really important.
But we were able to really operate
these digital cue cards effectively
and the crew had a lot
of really solid feedback
that said it was really helpful for
them to say, okay, if it's this type
of coral we want to sample
with this specific technology
and here's the procedure
for how to do that.
Toward the end of the mission
they didn't need those procedures
as much, but in the beginning
it really helped them sort
of refresh their memory
from the training they got
from the coral scientists.
And if there was a particularly
complex piece of machinery,
they could pull up the procedure.
If anything ever malfunctioned
we had procedures for that
in the cue cards which
they could pull them up.
And that increases this autonomy
and the feeling for the crew
that they can really do this
under a communication delay
and if they have a problem they
don't have to wait thirty minutes
for a troubleshooting procedure
on how to fix it from the shore.
And this is also a really efficient
way for the science team back
on Earth or on the shore
to iteratively evolve those
traverse plans from day to day.
So part of the procedure
was at the end
of every EVA the science team would
go and refine the traverse plan
for the next day and we could
upload that new traverse plan
to the cue card so it was waiting
for the astronauts the next day,
and which is something that
you can't do with pen and ink.
So from the IV support
station, or IV support sort
of workstation perspective,
we wanted to evaluate what assets
the IV crew member would need
to be successful in
helping the EV crew sort
of operate their traverse plan.
So this is Matthias, he's one
of the European astronauts,
he was a crew member last year,
and for that particular EVA he
was this IV person and he had
to monitor all of these
things at one time.
The EVAs are about four hours
long, so he's sitting at that desk
for four hours helping the EV crew
to operate the plan and get the data
from the science team as it evolves.
So we want to learn what
they need to be successful,
how many monitors is
too many monitors?
Is there a monitor where you can
put multiple things on one monitor
so you can minimize the sort of
desk space that the IV crew needs?
And what we really
have learned from NEEMO
and from the rover test before it is
that this IV role is
absolutely crucial.
They're really, really critical
especially under a time delay
in helping the EV crew
be successful.
And the reason for that is
that under a time delay,
I've sent a message up to the
crew and it doesn't get there
for fifteen minutes,
what if they're involved
in something really detailed with
their, you know, that they're doing
on the surface when that
communication comes through?
They get kind of annoyed when
someone's squawking in their ear,
that was something that was
relevant fifteen minutes ago,
that they're getting when they're
busy, but having this IV hub
as someone who can
receive that communication
and when there's a minute,
when there's a down minute,
they can pass it on to the
EV crew, is really important.
Especially when we're
doing reef exploration
where the coral scientists are
saying, ooh we want that coral,
we want that coral, pick that one.
We can use this IV person as a way
to streamline that communication.
And the way we do that is
through assets like this
that are displayed
on these computers.
So this is actually the mission
log that the IV crew member sees.
So this is a communication I
wrote last year to Matthias
and what it says is basically
we saw this view in one
of the EV crews cameras,
you know, half an hour ago,
we screenshotted it, drew a box
around it and said tell them
to go back to where you put
this number down and pick
up that coral, sample that coral.
And we can do that through the
IV person, so when Matthias sees
that come on his screen he says,
okay go back to where you put
down this tag number and then go
up an inch and sample there, right,
which is just not possible
if you're sending
that communication directly
to the EV crew member.
So we need to explore
these assets and figure
out exactly what the best thing
is for this person to have.
And then we have the
geology sampling system,
just a couple of photos
to show you the types
of samples that they could pick up.
It enables them to pick up loosely
adhered particles on the floor,
chip samples as well as
to take core samples.
So last year we were really
able to utilize this system,
it worked really well for taking and
storing samples which is relevant
for doing that and curating and
storing samples for return to Earth
in a Mars or Moon environment.
We also just briefly, I'll skim
through these, we had IV activities.
So we had a crew of four last
year, typically during the day,
two people would be on an EVA, one
person would be supporting them
from the IV position, which left
the fourth crew member to do things
like all of these really
exciting IV activities.
So we had a number of studies
which I won't dwell on but just
to highlight a couple,
this was the timeline tool
that NASA Ames deployed
for the mission
where the crew could keep
track of their own timeline
and you could actually get
into procedures from here.
So they're testing this
playbook timeline tool
and they're doing it
again this year for NEEMO.
Johns Hopkins ran sort of a
sensorimotor study, really exciting
and I'll have a slide on it in a
bit, is the mini DNA sequencer.
So Matthias is there actually
sequencing DNA underwater
and two months later Kate Rubins
sequenced DNA for the first time
in space on ISS, so that was
just really exciting to be a part
of last year and this is like
really cutting edge science
that is happening on
ISS, you know, today.
We also use the hollow lens, so
sort of augmented reality to figure
out for crew where they should
store and get a piece of gear.
So in a volume that's small,
everything is packed
really carefully
which means it's packed
really tightly
and sometimes you forget
where you put something.
But hollow lens can actually enable
you to say, okay ten days ago
where did I pack this little thing,
and you can actually put it on
and find it with augmented
reality in the habitat.
We are also testing
miniaturized exercise devices,
so one thing we're finding
with long-duration spaceflight
is it's really, really important
for astronauts to stay
fit and stay in shape,
and so we had an exercise team from
the Johnson Space Center with us.
We had a number of European Space
Agency Evaluations and we had things
like EVA swab tool which looks at
forward contamination by astronauts
in a spacesuit to make sure we're
not contaminating our working space.
Here's just a highlight
on the DNA sequencing,
so all the crew members
were able to get
through it last year,
Reed was very excited.
It's exciting!
So we had members of the mini ion
DNA sequencing team down in Florida
with us last year, here's Kate
after she successfully sequenced DNA
in space for the first time.
She was actually a molecular
biologist by training,
so this is really a
cool thing for her
to be able to actually get to do.
So this was just a real highlight
of last year and to working
out the procedures and how
to use it operationally
in a flight-like environment
during NEEMO actually prepares,
there's Matthias using in NEEMO,
prepared Kate to be
able to do it in space.
So that was NEEMO 21 briefly I'll
skim through - what time is it?
How much time do we have?
12:15, okay.
So NEEMO 22 is coming
up this summer,
so I'll just briefly highlight
some of the things we're going
to be doing that builds on
the success of NEEMO 21.
One is we're going to take cores
with a new breakaway core bit
technology that was developed
by Honeybee Robotics
which builds a lot
of the drills for the Mars rover.
So they're drilling
experts and so we're playing
with this new breakaway core bit
technology and deploying it in,
again, a mission flight-like
environment.
And it has relevancy to that geology
sampling system just with a sort
of a new core technology
and it's got a lot
of [inaudible] implications for
future sample storage on Mars.
Briefly again, I know this is sort
of hard to see, but we're playing
with tool transport on EVA.
So there's a lot of tools to sample
corals and also rocks on Mars.
So managing all these
tools in an environment
where if you drop something it'll
float away, is a nontrivial issue.
So what we're finding last year
is there were some frustrations
with managing, for
example; to sample corals,
you can chip them away or drill them
away and then you have to put them
in these small syringes and you
would imagine you're doing something
with both your hands, where are
you going to put the syringe,
you can't just put it down
because it will float away.
So managing all these tiny little
tools becomes a nontrivial problem.
So we're playing with equipment
transport and storage this year
and the EVA tools group at JSC
has done just an outstanding job
with thinking through this what
we're calling a modular equipment
transport system that's stored in
this cart that the crew has to pull
around with them while
they're on EVA and store all
of these sampling technologies.
One thing I'm really excited
about is I look at instruments
for astronauts to use on Mars,
so something that they'd hold
in their hand to actually
analyze the rocks real-time.
We have analogs for those
underwater, so we have sort
of two instruments that we're
deploying this year to look
at the photosynthetic state and
the metabolic state of corals.
So we're actually deploying those
instruments this year as well
and they can all, all this
stuff will fit both on the cart
and on the astronauts themselves
through a wrist storage
unit and a leg storage unit.
So they can pull out a syringe
from their wrists without having
to carry it long distances
from the cart.
So this is sort of the operating
strategy for every EVA, and again,
this was all sort of thought
up and then constructed
by the EVA tools group
that actually, you know,
builds tools for human spaceflight.
So the crew will egress from the
Aquarius habitat and they'll head
to the staging area
where their cart,
their modular equipment transport
system is waiting for them.
They'll arrive at the staging
area and pick the modules
from the staging area that they know
they're going to need for that EVA.
So if today's a day where I
need to deploy the instruments,
I'm going to make sure I get the
instrument modules and put them
on the cart because I
need them for that day.
You traverse through all these
coral towers and get to your zone
where you're going to
be exploring that day,
which the science team has
suggested as a plan for that day.
And here potentially in zone
"A" is three sites of interest
where we think, the science
team thinks they might be able
to find interesting coral colonies,
and they'll take the cart with them
to the zone and then take those
small modules with them to each site
so they don't have to drag
this big honking heavy cart
with them wherever they go.
Then they'll collect their samples,
return to the cart, and then return
to the staging area
at the end of the EVA.
So here's just some of
the types of the tools
that the tools group has
worked on in the modules
that we're going to be using.
We've got a drill for
sampling coral.
One of things that I thought has
been really interesting is this
pre-sampling module.
So if you have a crew
member who gets to a zone
that they've never been to before,
they take these little tags,
these little tags which are
about this big and they'll walk
around the zone and actually put
down a tag every time they think
there might be a coral of interest
and then they can come back later
and pick the most compelling samples
from those couple that
they've temporary tagged.
So we have the small tool module
for the little dexterous tools
that you need to actually put
the coral in the syringes,
and then you have the
actual syringes themselves
and where they're stored.
So these are some of the types
of modules that I'm talking
about that go in this cart.
For the IV support system this year,
we're evaluating a couple
different tools that will be running
in the background of
some of these monitors
that the IV person's
responsible for monitoring.
We're also want to minimize, I mean
this is ridiculous, like, you know,
this crazy for the IV person
to have to pay attention
to what the ground control
team is telling them
and what the EV crew
is telling them.
So we're trying to minimize the
number of computers and monitors
that are required for this IV
person to handle but, you know,
what we're finding is that all of
this software is just vital to,
you know, both mission safety and
the scientific success of a mission.
So we're playing with
the types of software
that the IV person
needs to be running.
For a science perspective, we're
retrieving the coral cards from both
of the nurseries, we call them
the Mercury and Atlas nurseries,
where the crew is going to retrieve
all the cards, transport the cards,
and, you know, document
any that may have died off
and potentially sample them if the
science team deems it's necessary.
They, then they'll take them
back, do the documentation
and the potential sampling, and then
they'll return the coral cards back
to the nursery and reconfigure
the cards in sort of this way.
So what it's been done
before is that each arm
of the coral nursery has the
cards hanging down off of them.
The Coral Restoration Foundation
found that they actually want
to flip them up and mount them
in a more stable configuration,
and that's one of the results
from actually being
able to do this study.
So it's exciting that we're seeing
a year later sort of a new action
that needs to be done for
this type of coral nursery.
For re-follow-up, we're going to
follow up on NEEMO 20 and NEEMO 21
to create this robust
three-year temporal assessment
of how the corals do
over a three-year period.
There actually have been disease
that's developed throughout the Keys
and one of the examples
of that disease development is
unfortunately around Aquarius.
So, but it's exciting that we get
a chance to potentially help figure
out what's going on with this
disease development around the Keys
and one of the areas that they're
going to do that is this year
at NEEMO around Aquarius.
And then they're just going
to explore new coral colonies
that they've already sort of
resampled from previous years
and tagged in previous
years and resample and look
at how they've developed overtime.
And then explore and
expand into new sites.
So we haven't covered this
entire Carpenter Basin
over the last couple years,
so we're going to explore
into newly explored sites
and deploy the instruments
to measure respiration
and photosynthesis using
these new instruments.
And then we're also going to
look at corals as they relate
to the colonies that are
deployed in the nurseries.
I'll skim through these, these
are just my last couple slides,
they're hard to read
so I can read them.
These are our science operations
objectives and they're split
into 4 Ts: tools, techniques,
technology, and training.
So for tools, we want to understand
how this modular transport system
relates to science driven EVAs,
does it help, does it hurt,
how operationally does
the crew use it,
how is the core sampling tool
going to be incorporated,
is it a timeline hit, is
it going to take longer
than the alternate
methods of sampling corals?
We're going to look at deploying
handheld instruments, like I said,
into science driven EVA which is
not something we've done before.
Technologies, what's
the role of informatics?
So those digital cue
cards, what's the role
that they play in science
driven EVAs?
What happens if you have a camera
mounted for situational awareness?
So if I'm working at this computer
as an outcrop and there's a camera
over here, how useful is that
camera for situational awareness
for the IV crew member and the
mission support team on Earth?
And again, the role
of the IV workstation,
because that's not something we've
done before past analog missions
like this.
Flexicution [phonetics], operational
flexibility is really important
so we're going to continue to
play with that and what tools
and technologies do
you need to develop
to support this flexible execution?
And what does the communication
flow look like?
I mentioned that's a
big deal especially
under communication delays.
So playing with the structure of
how data flows from one support team
to another to the crew is something
we'll need to continue to test.
And then training, we're not
only training the astronauts,
but we're also training
ourselves, the ground team.
So anybody who's involved in this
test gets a better understanding
of a flight-like environment
through a test like NEEMO,
and that's really important to
capture those lessons learned
as they evolve to make sure
that when we do this for real,
we're ready as a ground
team and as a crew.
And again, just to leave
you with a couple thoughts,
I think for outreach
this is really important,
we had a lot of excitement
over this image last year,
here's the six people who
are living in the habitat,
they're reading 20,000
Leagues Under the Sea.
And the reason they're wearing these
masks is that's what needs to happen
when you're in saturation, you want
to come back up to the surface,
you need to decompress
in a specific way,
so that's what they're doing here,
this is the last day
before they came up.
We had a lot of social media
following, we are excited
that Ellen Ochoa, the center
director of JSC got really
into it and tweeted something.
And one of the things that I
thought was especially cool
about last year was the EVA tools
group at Johnson Space Center works
with college students from around
the country to develop new ideas
for sampling in different
gravity environments.
So every year they run this
program, it's called Micro-g Next,
and they have university students,
you know, propose these ideas
and build these tools for
sampling in lower gravity.
And one of the tools that one of the
groups came up with last year was
to build this different type of
coring [assumed spelling] tube,
and the EVA tools group liked
it so much that they asked
and actually used it
in NEEMO last year,
so that was a pretty exciting
example of really fast
and testing from a university group.
And just sort of to leave you with
a sort of above and below life,
it really is a robust analog
project, you can see the LSB,
the life support buoy here.
This was a day where we had
two female crew members on EVA,
so we staffed mission control
with all the women there
which I thought was really neat.
A team picture from NEEMO 21 last
year, the two NASA astronauts
who were our crew last year,
Reid Wiseman and Megan Behnken.
And then this is Roger Garcia
who runs the entire facility,
and so he really enables
all of this stuff to happen.
So I'll leave this and I'll
take questions, thanks.
[ Applause ]
Yeah.
>> You said that the IV
role was really critical,
and this is the international group?
>> Kelsey Young: Yeah, this
is an international group.
>> This is an international group,
so we were seeing Matthias,
he was French or German.
>> Kelsey Young: Yeah, German.
>> German.
So, is he the only one or do
people rotate through the role?
>> Kelsey Young: Yeah,
so the question is,
we work with international
partners and is Matthias,
the astronaut from last
year, is he the only one
or do we have we other
international participation?
We definitely do.
So both of the two active Canadian
astronauts, David Saint-Jacques
and Jeremy Hansen have been
crew members already for NEEMO.
We've had most if not
all of the [inaudible],
the Japanese crew members, been
crew members on NEEMO and most
of the ESA, the European Space
Agency crew members have gone
through already.
And then we also have,
especially from ESA,
we've had support team
members come as well.
So we have the Capcom role, which is
the traditional role of the person
who sits in mission control in
Houston that communicates to ISS.
That Capcom role is filled by a
rotating cast of people for NEEMO
and we have international
Capcoms that come as well.
So we have a lot of international
participation with our sort
of partner or space agencies
and it's been I think one
of the more successful parts of the
mission, it's beenn exciting to see.
In the back.
>> Thank you, this is super awesome.
>> Kelsey Young: Oh, good.
>> You talk about the
nurseries, the coral nurseries.
What about any kind of prototyping
of nurseries for growing food
in this underground or aquatic -
>> Kelsey Young: Yeah.
>> station, and then what
are, what are they eating
and how are they preparing the food?
>> Kelsey Young: Yeah, so lots of
questions about food, which I love.
So, do they grow food
and what do they eat?
So they don't grow food in NEEMO,
we've done that with the rats
testing, the Rover testing.
We tested a habitat lab for rats and
we actually grew lettuce and ate it
at the end, it was delicious.
And they're doing that
on ISS of course.
They're growing vegetables
or lettuce
up on the International
Space Station.
In fact I think I saw this
morning or yesterday morning,
they were eating Chinese
cabbage, yeah.
So, yeah. What they, for here,
so one of the tricky
things operationally
about NEEMO is getting things
underwater is nontrivial.
So getting, for example, if you have
a bag of food that's not punctured
and you bring that volume
of air down sixty feet,
it doesn't react very well.
So any food that they get down
there is very carefully prepared.
For example, they have to
puncture all of their, like,
K cups for coffee before they
bring them down otherwise.
So, they eat, I mean they don't
eat anything out of the ordinary.
So they'll eat, I think one
crew in particular got really
into Pringles from what I hear.
They'll do dehydrated food, they
eat pretty normally down there.
Yeah, yeah.
>> You mentioned you're a geologist.
>> Kelsey Young: Yes.
>> And you're talking a lot about
the exciting things that lead
to the ISS and hopefully
boots on the ground.
Can you tell us a little bit about
where we are technology wise,
the radiation aspects on Mars?
And you talk about EVAs
that are four hours, if,
regardless of how long they were
there for a year or two years,
could they last for four hours at
this current status of technology?
>> Kelsey Young: Yeah.
>> What do we need to do to overcome
that so that it's a reality?
>> Kelsey Young: Yeah, so basically
what are the technological hurdles
to doing this on Mars.
There are a lot, radiation
you mentioned is a huge one.
So radiation shielding
and protecting
from space weather is huge.
We, you know, we got
lucky with Apollo,
we didn't have any major radiation
events while the astronauts were
on the surface, we can't guarantee
that that's going to happen again.
So protecting from radiation,
especially for the long durations
it'll take to get to Mars,
stay on Mars, and get back,
is extremely nontrivial.
So that's a major area of ongoing
technology development right now.
Launch and landing is
a big deal as well.
So landing that much
mass on the surface
of Mars is really challenging.
The most we've landed is the
MSL rover, the curiosity rover,
that's up there right now and we did
that with this incredibly complex
and really cool sky train
technology where it sort of braked
and then thrusters fired and
it hovered above the ground
and a crane actually
lowered down the rover,
which like blows my mind
every time we think about,
we did that successfully.
But the mass required for
human habitation is, you know,
orders of magnitude
larger than that rover.
So figuring out how to, you
know, get human beings to Mars
and land them safely is another
ongoing area of research.
Of course you may have
heard in the news
about the SLS rocket launch system,
this, the heavy launch vehicle
that NASA's developing, that's
an ongoing area of research
that NASA is heavily
involved in right now.
So from a big picture, you know,
we have the rockets, we have launch
and landing, we have
radiation, we have human health
for long-term spaceflight.
So what happens to a
human body when they're
in low gravity for that long.
So those are sort of the
big picture questions
that NASA is doing a really good
job of investigating right now.
From a geology standpoint,
which is the stuff
that I spend my days thinking about,
a lot of the stuff I mentioned,
even though NEEMO is
underwater and they're looking
at corals, is incredibly relevant.
Operationally, you know, yes
we've done before like, you know,
humans collected a lot of really
interesting science samples
from Apollo but technology has come
a long way since then and hopefully
when human beings do this for real
they'll have more robust instruments
that they're able to use.
And figuring out how to incorporate
those into EVA is important,
figuring out how to design
the hardware and software
for EVA is important, and that's,
you know, the types of people
that I work with are working
on that right now, so.
>> [ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Kelsey Young: So I do not claim
to be any a member of their team,
I was thrilled to work
with them, next to them,
but I'm definitely not
on the team for that.
But to answer your question as best
I can which was about, you know,
operating the mini DNA sequencer.
They basically get the sample,
and the instrument itself is
like this big and they actually feed
the sample in and it runs, I mean,
pretty quickly in a
matter of an hour or two,
at least the sequences they
were running on NEEMO last year.
And they do, they download the
data locally and then they have
to send it up in a big chunk.
Yeah.
>> As a diver I'm just
curious about the decompression
that they have to go through.
You said sixteen days
was the longest?
>> Kelsey Young: Yeah.
Well I, I don't know if
that's the longest ever,
that was what NEEMO 21 was.
Yeah.
>> I was wondering if that was
because of decompression
Earth [inaudible].
>> Kelsey Young: No that was,
so why the sixteen-day duration
in terms of saturation diving?
Definitely not the limit, it was
just what we had available to us
in terms of scheduling
for NASA last year.
I'm pretty sure there
have been longer missions.
It doesn't have to do with
the saturation limits at all.
We do have to be careful,
and they have this
down to an absolute
science at this facility.
We don't want to go too deep
on the EVA's for too long.
So planning the EVA's revolves
of course around safety first
and so the crew at the Aquarius Reef
Base facility basically gives us our
unbreakable flight rules
and they monitor every EVA
to make sure the crews aren't
staying too deep too long.
>> And they all train divers?
>> Kelsey Young: Yes,
yes saturation divers do,
they go through special
saturation dive training.
Thanks.
>> Nanette Gibbs: Thank
you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.